controlling an autonomous vehicle in
order to accomplish a task requires an
understanding of many aspects of the
problem from the vehicles dynamics to
obstacles to avoid to the values of each
objective it can be inefficient
error-prone or impossible for human
operators to specify a detailed action
sequence thus it is important to elevate
the level of commanding such that human
operators only need to specify a set of
goals to be accomplished and then have
planners produce a series of actions
that achieve the mission goals based on
the model of the physical plant under
control the environment and the
objectives the planner integration
project combines the capabilities of two
planners to provide a robust planning
framework we demonstrate the
integrations capabilities on Odyssey for
an autonomous underwater vehicle or a UV
designed and built by the MIT a UV lab
at Sea Grant the auv has an ability to
dive ascend and glide as well as to take
pictures and CTD readings we can specify
a set of tasks for the auv to complete
the interface allows us to place start
and finish locations manipulate
obstacles place waypoints and enable
discrete actions such as taking a
picture or recording video here a user
is creating a simple task involving
three waypoints surrounding an obstacle
after setting the starting point the
user specifies the desired Waypoint
surrounding the obstacle and also moves
the goal point to the desired location
the yellow edges between the nodes
represent the high-level plan designed
by the operator which crosses an
obstacle in its way Kirk calculates the
first layer of the plan to go around the
obstacle shown here as the green path
finally the red path shows the complete
plan which is the result of calming
refinement the auv executed the plan
successfully in open water the final
trajectory shows the initial movement of
the auv to the start followed by the way
the artifacts from the control as a more
difficult task the auv was tasked with
drawing AK in the ocean the
v executed the plan successfully in open
water the actual trajectory is plotted
in Google Earth the planner integration
project shows not only the successful
integration of Kirk and cong ming but
their interoperation with a vehicle in a
real-world environment